et tout de suite vu de Russie
bienvenue dans une édition spéciale de
vue de Russie ce soir Elena Volochine
vous revenez sur la propagande de
Vladimir Poutine qui tente de sauver son
image après le putschu raté du chef de
guerre yougaini prix gojin et Lena
bonsoir bonsoir Stéphanie en effet ce
coup de force de la plongé le régime de
Vladimir Poutine dans une crise majeure
et sans précédent depuis la chute de
l'URSS c'était vendredi dernier le
patron des Wagner publié sur ses chaînes
télégram cette déclaration choc où il
démontait en bloc le mythe officiel de
Vladimir Poutine qui est justifie sa
guerre en Ukraine par la denésification
et la démilitarisation et pris augines
désigne aussi ses ennemis écouter
rappelez-vous
[Musique]
la guerre ce n'était pas pour faire
revenir dans notre giron les citoyens
russes et ce n'était pas pour des
militariser et des nazifié l'Ukraine il
fallait la guerre parce qu'il fallait
une étoile brodée à son périmètre pour
qu'un homme à l'esprit malade se voit
t'apporter cette étoile sur un coussin
lorsqu'il s'allongera dans son cercueil
et deuxièmement il fallait cette guerre
aux oligarques le clan oligarchie au
pouvoir n'a qu'une idée en tête comment
traîner son corps le plus longtemps
possible et que ce corps soit dans la
meilleure condition possible ils en sont
atteints dans leur cerveau
et pourquoi cette déclaration a-t-elle
fait peur à Poutine et bien parce qu'il
y a béni Prigogine la désignée sans le
nommer lorsque Prigogine parle du
général qui rêve d'une étoile de
Marshall dans son cercueil de maréchal
et bien il parle de sergueilleux son
ennemi juré le ministre russe de la
Défense mais lorsqu'il parle des
oligarques qui se sont fait construire
des hôpitaux pour soigner leur cancer et
assurer leur longévité et bien là il
désigne sans le nommer Vladimir Poutine
et son clan de Saint-Pétersbourg c'est
oligares qui sont arrivés au pouvoir en
même temps que lui plus tard dans la
soirée il y a gagné Prigogine annonce
marcher sur Moscou pour prendre les
institutions à la tête d'une armée de
25000 mercenaires il menace d’abattre
quiconque se dresse se dressera pardon
sur son chemin il entre en Russie et
occupe la ville de Rostov sur le don au
sud à 1h30 du matin la présentatrice
vedette de pirvana la première chaîne
russe il y a katyril va prendre
l'antenne pour une édition spéciale elle
lit des communiqués de presse officielle
dont celui du FSB le Service fédéral de
la sécurité qui lance une enquête contre
Prigogine pour appel à insurrection
armée
des actions déclarées par Afghani
prigogi n’estime le FSB et qui va la des
appels à un conflit civil sur le
territoire du pays c'est un coup de
poignard dans le dos de nos soldats qui
combattent les forces prof fascistes
d'ukrainienne le FSB estime que tout
ceci est une provocation
informationnelle et appelle les
combattants de la société Wagner à ne
pas commettre des erreurs irréparables à
cesser toutes les actions violentes
contre le peuple russe ne pas obéir aux
ordres traîtres et criminels de
prégogène et a tout faire pour l'arrêter
immédiatement voilà les mots de traîtres
et coup de poignard dans le dos sont
prononcés à partir de là toute la
communication officielle sera
verrouillée les médias rues sentiendront
encore plus que d'habitude à la lecture
de ces communiqués 40 minutes plus tard
l'édition spéciale est rediffusée avec
cette fois-ci en ouverture une
déclaration enregistrée du général
Sergueï celui qui commande la guerre en
Ukraine appelle les Wagner à obéir aux
ordres je cite du président élu par le
peuple Vladimir Poutine des sources
américaines citées par le New York Times
affilt affirme que ce serait bien Souro
viking
qui aurait aidé pris d'origine dans sa
mutinerie et cette déclaration à
diffusée dans le journal télévisé russe
et bien elle aurait peut-être pu être
décisive pour la décision ensuite de
priscogyne d'abandonner son projet de
prendre Moscou mais dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi les Wagner parviennent
tout de même à s'emparer de la ville de
rostof Le don et du
QG des forces armées russes sur place
une situation grave elle force
d'ailleurs vladir Poutine à sortir de
son silence oui dans une allocution qui
semble elle aussi avoir été préparée à
l'avance Vladimir Poutine répète mot
pour mot c'est terme de traîtrise et de
coups de poignard dans le dos il évoque
aussi une menace mortelle pour la Russie
je le cite et il promet un châtiment
innommable au traître qui répondront
promet-il devant la loi et devant le
peuple de leurs actes cependant plus
tard ce jour-là toutes les poursuites
judiciaires contre les Wagner seront
abandonnés lorsque Prigogine annoncera à
faire demi-tour mais en attendant ces
troupes occupent donc Rostov ils
marchent vers Moscou le Kremlin panique
la chaîne d'information continue aussi à
24 elle se met à diffuser en boucle non
pas des reportages et des directs depuis
Rostov mais des films documentaires
d'archives dont celui dont vous allez
voir un extrait il reste dans cette
thématique d'attiser la haine envers les
ennemis intérieurs et extérieurs de la
Russie qui voudrait la détruire maison
bien loin des événements du jour
regardez
en 1991 Gerard Doudaev a déclaré
l'indépendance de la Tchétchénie
vis-à-vis de la Fédération de Russie
vous dites que vous avez des preuves
comme quoi les États-Unis soutenaient
secrètement les terroristes tchétchène
bien sûr pour ce qui est du soutien
politique et informationnel cela se
passe de preuves c'est évident pour tout
le monde
la deuxième guerre de Tchétchénie a mis
un terme au banditisme pas seulement en
Tchétchénie mais dans toute la Russie
voilà le célèbre cinéaste russe Nikita à
micraulco enfin fidèle de Vladimir
Poutine en fait l'apologie de la
deuxième guerre de Tchétchénie lancé par
Poutine en 99 il parle des ennemis
intérieurs et extérieurs donc les
États-Unis autres reportages diffusaient
le jour de cette tentative de coup
d'état avortée de Prigogine à Moscou
celui sur les funérailles de l'ex
Premier ministre italien Silvio
Berlusconi
politique qui émet son pays et c'était
réciproque l'homme qui avait appris à
l'Italie à rêver ne laisse à l'Italie
que le vide et des souvenirs
[Applaudissements]
voilà des images qui est donc date du
qui date donc pardon du 14 juin au même
moment la Russie elle semble au bord
d'un bain de sang car les convois armés
de Wagner progresse toujours vers Moscou
pour prendre les institutions et puis
soudain en cette fin d'après-midi samedi
dernier le président biélorus Alexandre
lucaschenko annonce avoir trouvé un
accord avec
ievini pris gojin il décide dans la
foulée le chef de guerre de faire
demi-tour à ce moment-là les journaux
télévisés du soir diffusent enfin des
reportages depuis Rostov regardez
[Musique]
dans l'ensemble on peut dire que la
situation est calme allons voir ces gens
qui filment avec leur téléphone portable
dites nous s'il vous plaît vous qui
revenez de là-bas qu'est-ce qui s'y
passe
à la cathédrale devant l'icône de la
Vierge Marie du don qui a toujours
protégé le peuple contre les ennemis
extérieurs et les dissensions
intérieures le métropolith Mercouri
s'adresse aux habitants du don et à
leurs autres
le peuple sait que vous avez combattu
avec honnêteté et bravoure
use ne salissez pas la gloire de vos
armes par la honte des conflits internes
et tout de suite après la pluie s'est
mise à tomber elle n'a pas vidé les rues
mais calmer les esprits l'équilibre est
fragile chacun attend mais personne ne
croit qu'un malheur puisse arriver
un discours quasiment messianique dans
la veine de sur la guerre sacrée du
peuple que l'on entend sans arrêt en
Russie sur fond d'agression contre
l'Ukraine et un discours qui tend aussi
à minimiser la gravité de la situation
oui à partir de ce moment-là en fait les
chaînes de télévision russe elle feront
tout pour souligner le retour à la
normale se reportage que l'on a vu sur
terre de canard avait été tourné avant
le retrait des Wagner qui a commencé aux
alentours de 18 de 19h30 pardon un heure
locale ce qui nous a frappé pendant ce
retrait souvenez-vous c'était ses
applaudissements et c'est hourra de la
foule au convoi de Wagner prigogi
lui-même s'est offert un petit bain de
foule dans son pick-up ces images les
chaînes de télévision russe ne les ont
évidemment pas montré en revanche dans
le reportage que vous allez voir on
entend les applaudissements de la foule
mais le commentaire fait croire et bien
que c'était dû au soulagement de voir
les Wagner repartir et à la gratitude
envers Vladimir Poutine regardez allez
au marché promener son chien un nouveau
jour se lève je vais chercher des fleurs
pour ma grand-mère la veille au soir
escortée par la police la colonne
militaire des Wagner a quitté Rostov et
les gens dans les rues ne cachent pas
pas leur joie en disant on y croyait
tout finirait vite et le bon sens
triomphé
[Musique]
soutien Poutine c'est donc soutenir la
paix au lendemain de cette crise sans
précédent Elena l'objectif principal de
la propagande russe c'est vraiment de
sauver l'image du président russe oui et
c'est ce à quoi va s'employer à J + 1
des dimanches soirs une émission
intitulée Moscou Kremlin Poutine c'est
une hebdomadaire elle est diffusée
depuis 2018 et elle est entièrement
dédiée au culte de la personnalité du
président le concept c'est ce
journaliste que vous voyez à l'écran
peuvent ZAR Robin il suit Poutine
partout pour lui forger l'image d'un
président moderne et accessible
l'exercice est évidemment
ultra contrôlé mais contrairement aux
autres journalistes zarubin il a
toujours un accès privilégié de quelques
instants pour tendre son micro à Poutine
et dimanche soir donc il avait pour
mission de faire croire que tout était
normal ou presque sous les ordres du
Kremlin regardez
toute la nuit le président était en lien
avec les forces de sécurité le jour des
événements difficiles seul notre équipe
de tournage a eu accès au Kremlin je
m'adresse aux citoyens de la Russie vous
verrez comment le président a travaillé
derrière les porte-closes on peut vous
appeler à n'importe quelle heure même la
nuit si c'est important
nous vous révélerons les détails
exclusifs de cette semaine tendue
problème sur la deuxième partie de ces
images quand ZAR Robin est avec Poutine
et qui lui demande si les joignable un
apport quelle heure du jour ou des et ou
de la nuit c'est une image d'archives
elle est extraite d'un autre reportage
qui avait déjà été diffusé 10 jours plus
tôt lors d'une rencontre de Vladimir
Poutine avec les diplômés des écoles
militaires alors vous l'avez entendu
événement difficile semaine tendu les
euphémismes sont là pour dire que oui
Vladimir Poutine a passé un durement
mais finalement rien d'extraordinaire et
surtout dans son reportage pasvel a
robin fait semblant que comme toujours
il suit le président sauf que
contrairement à toujours à aucun moment
on ne les voit tous les deux ensemble à
l'écran regardez attentivement
les caméras et les photographes se
dépêchent d'installer leur caméra
quelques minutes plus tard il dit
bonjour Comme d'habitude
son allocution était enregistrée à 9h55
et à 10h tout le pays l'a vu voilà
l'allocution de Poutine est enregistrée
Poutine à qualifier les événements de
traîtrise et trahison à la Russie bien
sûr le travail du Kremlin est passé en
ce moment en régime d'exception nous
vous tiendrons au courant de la suite
c'est un sujet de quelques minutes pour
montrer que la situation est certes
tendue mais pas assez pour déstabiliser
Vladimir Poutine on se demande
d'ailleurs si ce journaliste zarubine a
vraiment eu accès à lui comme à
l'ordinaire oui et celui qui n'en menait
pas large quant à lui est bien c'était
le présentateur de l'émission le célèbre
propagandiste russe Vladimir solov un
pilier de la propagande russe recordman
du nombre d'heures à l'antenne capable
de tenir 25 heures d'antenne par semaine
il tenait cette fois là difficilement
debout il est connu pour ses salves
théâtrales lorsqu'il appelle à la guerre
nucléaire ou à détruire le diable
américain et bien ce soir là il est
l'ombre de lui-même lorsqu'il parle d'un
ton égal des ennemis de la Russie ou
bien des bateaux-mouches regardez
c'était une dure journée très dure mais
le peuple a fait son choix le peuple a
soutenu la Russie le peuple a soutenu le
président
et où je connais et comme tous les
ennemis de la Russie se sont fourvoyés
comme les médias occidentaux sifflés
ululés
poubelles se réjouissaient
et quelle déception on les attendait le
soir
est le maire de Moscou ont inauguré dans
la capitale russe un bateau-mouche qui
circulera toute l'année c'est le premier
transport maritime au monde entièrement
électrique
de la propagande de montrer que tout est
sous contrôle que le régime a néanmoins
vaciller toute la question est de savoir
si le Kremlin garde véritablement le
contrôle de la situation alors depuis
samedi c'est passé une série de choses
assez étranges et inédite dans la Russie
de Vladimir Poutine en dehors évidemment
de la tentative de putsch elle-même
regardez d'abord ces images du Conseil
de sécurité ou Poutine a réuni certains
responsables dont son ministre de la
Défense servait goût la bête noire de
yefghani Prigogine shoyout est en civil
et non pas en treillis pour la première
fois depuis le début de la guerre en
Ukraine comptable Vladimir Poutine un
rictus déforme sa bouche lorsqu'il parle
regardez le début de cet extrait n'est
pas traduit pour que l'on puisse se
concentrer sur l'image
[Musique]
il n'y a que très peu d'images de cette
réunion regardez les mains du chef de la
garde nationale on a fait quelques gros
plans des participants à la réunion
parce qu'en ce moment ces images sont
minutieusement scrutées on regarde les
visages on sera plus tard ce qui s'est
dit lors de cette réunion
voilà ce sujet il est aussi réalisé et
commenté par Pavel zarubin pour
l'émission Moscou Kremlin Poutine sauf
que et bien il ne sera finalement pas
diffusé dans cette émission je l'ai vu
uniquement sur la chaîne d'information
continue Rossia 24 vous l'avez entendu
ZAR Robin et peut-être aller trop loin
en attirant lui-même sans le dire
l'attention sur les visages et sur les
gros plans de Vladimir Poutine toujours
est-il que des choses inhabituelles dans
la communication du Kremlin continue de
se prédire et lundi matin soit agi plus
2 après le putsch avorté Poutine
apparaît dans une courte allocution
diffusée par le service de presse du
Kremlin il est seul il est sans
contre-champ et il salue les
participants invisibles d'un forum de
jeunes ingénieurs il n'a aucun écran
face à lui comme toujours dans ce genre
de cas et on ne voit pas non plus cette
image on l'a pas trouvé sur les chaînes
de télévision russe et sur leur site
alors que d'habitude elle diffuse
intégralement toutes les interventions
du Président ensuite mardi Vladimir
Poutine il réapparaît pour une cérémonie
en hommage assez militaire qui aurait
repoussé Wagner dans leur tentative de
putsch et encore une fois il s'adresse à
des fantômes lors de cette allocution
sur la place des cathédrales du Kremlin
que vous voyez dans ces images parce que
dans les premières images diffusées à
14h par la télévision russe perle
vécanau et bien il n'y a toujours pas de
contre-champs Poutine pendant près de 5
minutes on ne voit que lui à l'image y
compris pendant la minute de silence en
l'honneur des pilotes d'hélicoptère mort
pendant l'offensive de Prigogine
regardez
[Applaudissements]
voilà on a joué 10 secondes de 7 minutes
de silence qui dure en réalité 35
secondes soit une éternité télévisuelle
c'est long et pas gratifiant pour
l'image de Vladimir Poutine de le voir
seul ainsi mais ce n'est qu'en fin
d'après-midi qu'on verra les images du
contre-champ les militaires sur la place
qui sont censés l'écouter mais à aucun
moment on ne voit Poutine et les
militaires ensemble ce qui laisse
entendre que peut-être et bien ces
images auraient pu en tout cas être
retournée à différents montants moments
et monter ensemble il s'agirait
peut-être d'assurer là par là la
sécurité du président russe alors que il
a fait face comme il l'a dit lui-même à
une menace mortelle on l'a quand même vu
dans une salle face à ceux qui étaient
présentés comme des militaires assis de
dos se nase là n'arrive jamais non plus
en général à on voit les visages de ceux
qui l'écoutent mais là il n'y avait que
ces quelques images ou bien on ne voyait
pas grand chose
une communication inhabituelle donc pour
le Kremlin deux jours après la cérémonie
Vladimir Poutine c'est pourtant offert
un bain de foule au Daguestan le seul
endroit de la Russie où il y a eu des
manifestations contre la mobilisation
des hommes pour aller combattre en
Ukraine voilà ce qui surprend c'est le
contraste entre les images au Kremlin et
ce bain de full au Dagestan parce que
c'est du jamais vu dans la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine le Dagh estan est une
république musulmane au sud de la Russie
dans la région du Caucase et l'accueil
Vladimir Poutine qui tout d'un coup fait
des bisous serre des mains fait des
selfies avec la foule il serait aussi
allé visiter la citadelle historique de
Derbent cette ville du Daguestan connue
pour pour être voilà un lieu touristique
très prisé il aurait déambulé dans les
rues de la vieille ville regardez cette
séquence là aussi c'est le journaliste
Pavel zarubin qui suit Poutine et cette
fois il est bien dans le format qu'on
lui connaît c'est-à-dire qu'on le voit à
l'image en même temps que Poutine a
quelques mètres de lui à regarder
footing est venu voir la nouvelle
fontaine et en voyant les habitants de
derben il s'est dirigé vers eux les gens
veulent des photos mais s'exclame aussi
commandant en chef
[Applaudissements]
en ce moment nous voyons Poutine se
diriger tout droit vers les habitants de
derben regardez comme il est accueilli
en 7 secondes
et c'est déjà le deuxième endroit sur la
place centrale de la ville
[Applaudissements]
Poutine qui malgré sa guerre contre
l'Ukraine reste populaire aux yeux de
certains russes sur ces sur les réseaux
sociaux pourtant Elena certains trouvent
ces images très étranges je pense même
qu'il s'agirait d'un sosie oui on voit
de tels messages même chez les blogueurs
procrement parce qu'encore une fois ces
images elles sont juste inexplicables
Poutine qui s'offrent un bain de full
spontané on n'avait jamais vu ça en 23
ans au pouvoir alors cela surprend
encore plus 5 jours après un coup d'état
manqué alors qu'il parlait lui-même
encore une fois d'une menace mortelle
pour pour lui et son régime mais
décidément depuis une semaine et bien
bien des choses semblent avoir changé
regarder pour finir ce conseil des
ministres qui s'est tenu lundi le
reportage que vous allez voir à lui
était diffusé mercredi le Premier
ministre russe Mika michoustine il parle
de développer le tourisme agit plus deux
de la tentative de putsch de ya fini
Prigogine donc et comme nous le suggéré
le journaliste Pavel zarubins scruter
les gros plans et les visages des
ministres
mes collègues j'attire votre attention
sur la nécessité de continuer à dépenser
les fonds d'État de la façon la plus
efficace possible vous devez remplir
toutes les obligations sociales envers
nos citoyens
enfin un thème qui concerne des millions
de Russes sur tout maintenant en période
de congé d'été comment soutenir le
tourisme intérieur la demande est en
hausse toutes ces dernières années il
faut conserver même démultiplier la
dynamique positive beaucoup a déjà été
fait pour le confort des touristes
notre pays est connu pour la beauté de
sa nature et pour ses monuments
historiques de différentes époques pour
sécher leur artistique de renommer
mondiale pour sa culture diverses et
multinationale bien sûr des millions de
nos concitoyens et d'autres étrangers
veulent voir tout cela
encore une fois on en est réduit à
interpréter oui alors imaginez une armée
de mercenaires et de repris de justice
qui marche sur Paris pour prendre le
ministère de la Défense et la télévision
nous nous diffusions des reportages sur
le tourisme il est difficile de savoir
et de commenter ce qui se passe vraiment
en ce moment dans les coulisses du
pouvoir en Russie ce que l'on peut dire
à coup sûr c'est que la pyramide a
vaciller et finalement en ces jours sans
précédent dans l'histoire russe la
propagande russe elle nous en dit
peut-être plus long qu'il n'y paraît
alors qu'on a pu observer à vue d'oeil
ces symptômes d'un régime qui a planché
il est difficile encore de poser un
diagnostic car ce régime il se referme
et il joue aussi son va tout pour sauver
les apparences
merci Elena c'est tout pour vue de
Russie à la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine
merci de nous avoir suivis et on se
retrouve dans un peu moins de 5 minutes
à nouveau journal et puis 19h10 une
semaine dans le monde on revient sur les
grandes une internationales de la
semaine avec nos éditorialistes on va
bien se revenir sur ce putsch avorter de
Prigogine on va revenir également sur
les émeutes urbaines en France ça sera
19h10 reste avec nous